and
blood passion tells the story of the
ludlow massacre in 1914
in response to union strikes in southern
colorado local militiamen became
entangled in a fight covering 200 miles
and claiming over 30 lives
president woodrow wilson sent in the u.s
army to quell the labor battle the
author scott martel spoke about blood
passion recently at the tattered cover
bookstore in denver for about 45 minutes
hi thank you all for coming uh let me
start off with a caveat um there may be
some awkward pauses on the delivery
tonight because as a journalist i'm
usually the one in the back with a
notebook i'm not used to the public
speaking so i have to have to give me a
little bit of patience here
i think the easiest way to start this is
to tell a little bit about why i did
this project um i've been interested in
labor and progressive history uh since
college i guess when i read uh john does
paso's usa trilogy i became kind of
infatuated with that era in american
history
and the experience was in 1995 detroit
newspaper strike i spent 18 months on
the picket line kind of sensitized me to
labor issues
in the and after about five years ago i
was reading a book and i can't remember
the name of the book for the life i keep
looking on my shelves for but i can't
find it
i saw a footnote and it referred to the
ludlow massacre and i knew about the
london massacre
but it also referred to 100 some people
being killed in the cold war that
surrounded the ludlow massacre
and it floored me it's like how the hell
did i not know that why was that not a
big part of the school work that i did
and the big part about the other books
that i've been reading
and it just sort of started me in a
quest to try to find out more about this
event
as it turns out that footnote was wrong
the death toll was actually 75.
uh but i was working for the latest to
work for the la times and i started
poking around into the story and at that
time i don't know how close you folks
were following what's been going on in
ludlow but
dean sada and some other professors he's
at the university of denver we're doing
an archaeological dig in the site of the
tent colony itself i thought perfect
story being a good way to get to the
ludlow massacre i couldn't persuade my
editors at the paper that was a good
story
so i thought about it for a while
decided well i'll do a little more
research maybe propose this as a
magazine piece for harper's or atlantic
monthly one of those
and started digging around digging
around digging around and quickly
realized that there was a whole book to
be done here and that became my
obsession
worked on it piecemeal for about a year
and a half or so
then i got to the expensive part of the
research going to archives doing that
kind of thing and i decided that that
would be a good time to see if i could
find an outlet for this project before i
invested too much more time and money in
it
and rutgers university press agreed to
publish the book
so after the races finished the book
about a year ago and it came out uh just
last week
um
probably the best way to dis to describe
the overview of what happened there and
we take these glasses off a lot i'm not
quite to the bifocal stage but i think i
need to be is read you a little bit from
the introduction that talks about what
happened back then
hot summer winds whisk across the
colorado prairie with a distracting
persistence kicking up small dust devils
and swirls of debris that whisper
eastward over interstate 25 and on into
the vast flatness of the great plains
a freeway sign at exit 27 says this spot
is the town of ludlow but there's no
town here just a chain-link fence with
an unlocked gate surrounding a
white-walled meeting hall a gazebo with
picnic tables and a monument that looks
like an oversized victorian grave marker
a half dozen isolated ranchettes some
with metal bar horse carols dot the
sweeping countryside giving the place a
forgotten feel like a grange hall amid
farms gone fallow
a rusty railroad runs north and south
like a seam stitching the prairie to the
sangre de cristo mountains
in one direction lies colorado springs
and farther north denver the opposite
direction takes you to trinidad and on
across the old santa fe trail into new
mexico
on the west side of the tracks a
washboard road curls into a canyon
leading to the ghost towns of hastings
in dalagua
a little to the south another dirt road
trails into another canyon to yet more
ghost towns
berlin and tabasco reduced now to tan
clusters of crumbling stones along a
gurgling creek the only sound say for
the occasional chirp of a bird or the
rustle of dry leaves and grasses
cole once was king here but emptiness
now reigns and it doesn't take much of a
romantic flight to hear the footfalls of
the dead
less than a century ago this quiet and
mostly empty stretch of southern
colorado was the scene of great strife
and great agony more than 75 people died
most of them shot to death in the first
eight months of a cold strike that
lasted 15 months and that the miners
lost
the united states had endured violent
labor battles before and there have been
many since
none though reached the level of pitched
warfare that erupted here in colorado's
southern coal fields where east coast
money and power collided with immigrant
poverty in need
that's
a little bit more the nader came on a
sunny monday morning in april 1914 when
a detachment from the colorado national
guard engaged in a 10-hour gun battle
with union men at ludlow where a tent
colony housing some 1100 strikers and
their families had been erected
seven men and a boy were killed in the
shooting at least three of the men all
striking minors one a leader apparently
were executed in cold blood by colorado
national guardsmen who had taken them
captive
as the sun set the militia moved into
the camp itself and
an inferno lit up the darkening sky
reducing most of the makeshift village
to ashes
it wasn't until the next morning that
the bodies of two mothers and 11
children were discovered where they had
taken shelter in a dirt bunker beneath
one of the tents
the raging fire had sucked the oxygen
from the air below suffocating the
families as they hid from the gun battle
the deaths of the women and children
quickly became known as ludlow massacre
and the backlash was vicious and bloody
over the next 10 days striking miners
and their supporters poured out their
rage and attacks across the coal fields
in quote and armed an open rebellion
against the authority of the state as
represented by the militia
this rebellion constituted perhaps one
of the nearest approaches to civil war
and revolution ever known in this
country in connection with an industrial
conflict
and it was a guerrilla war that
stretched along more than 200 miles of
the eastern slope of the colorado
rockies
union men mostly greek and italian
immigrants swept in from the hillsides
and burned mineworks to the ground
before disappearing
guards and strike breakers were killed
at one point several dozen mine
officials guards scabs and their
families were holed up in a mine shaft
the entry partially sealed by dynamite
blast with rampaging miners ready to
kill if they came out it took the us
army to bring the bloodshed to an end
ten days later after another 30 people
were killed and dozens of mine buildings
leveled
obviously that was a violent convulsion
in that era
in those few weeks
but it began much earlier than that um
previous histories on the ludlow
massacre tend to paint the miners as
kind of virtuous victims of what had
happened
uh the reality is much different they
were victims they the coal companies
they work for
control almost all of the towns around
the mines themselves it's all privately
owned comp uh property
they're called closed towns closed camps
the company owned everything they own
the houses the workers lived in they
owned the store where you had to shop
with with company script even though it
was illegal
uh if you shopped if you snuck out to
wallsenberg or trinidad or some place
for to go shop at a regular store and
the managers found out they fired you
they sent you down canyon as they called
it
um there were no political rights uh
especially in herefore no county where
wallsenberg is the sheriff there a guy
by the name of jefferson b far is kind
of a caricature of a sheriff big beefy
guy red-faced
ran most of the corrupt practices in
juefenelle county most of them from the
back room of the saloon he owned
he controlled all the votes in that
county in the closed camps so he would
wait on election day to see how the the
open part of the county was voting and
then report out the votes from the
closed mine camps quite often counting
votes for sheep for the candidate that
he wanted and he never lost a race it
was an incredible system he had set up
one of his partners incidentally
was a top manager with a colorado fuel
and iron company so jefferson fires
candidates were almost always the coal
company candidates and the workers had
the only rights the workers had in the
eyes of the coal operators was the right
to quit the job
and and that's the kind of system that
they're rebelling against
um the first death in
the cold war actually came before the
strike
uh the strike began the strike in the
southern district the strike began in
the northern district in 1910
and the unions were losing it uh after
two and a half three years the coals
were back to operating almost at at
their full capacity and united mine
workers of america decided that the only
way they were going to
win the strike was to escalate things
and make it essentially statewide and
they decided to organize a southern
district
in august of 1913
there was a state trades council meeting
federation of labor meeting in trinidad
and one of the top issues on their
agenda was to talk about the the
condition of the mines and the strike on
the north and the organizing on the
south
and the mine workers sent down a guy
named gerald lipiott who was born in
england raised
mostly in ohio after his family
immigrated when he was a kid
moved west to make his fortune got
involved in the coal mines got involved
with the union and by august he was
an organizer and they sent him down from
i think he was in lafayette at the time
and sent him down to trinidad to
both organize and help out this trades
council
but he also had a bit of a history in
the northern field in the strike
the coal operators to maintain order
hired and to also keep the union out
hired the baldwin felt detective agency
which is kind of a variation of the
pinkertons most of their work was
dedicated to breaking unions or keeping
track of union organizing drives
and they had a bunch of gun-toting uh
detectives who worked for them these
guys again were kind of like caricatures
of the old west
there was one guy
named
belcher
i'll just start here and you get a sense
of this guy
this is a saturday night august 15 1913
gerard lipiat is walking from the train
station of commercial street to the
heart of downtown trinidad to the toltec
hotel
and to a nearby block of buildings
where the union had its offices
two of the baldwin feltz gunmen walter
belk and george belcher were hanging
around outside the toltec hotel the
night lipiat was making his way through
the trinidad crowd
belk 30 had been in colorado since
december 1912 after directing a
contingent of baldenfeld's gunman in
pink creek where one confrontation led
to his arrest on murder charges although
the case was dismissed before it reached
trial
belcher the other detective was 26 he
was in west virginia but had been in
colorado for several years and had not
been involved in that west virginia
paint creek strike
he was the more flamboyant of the two
detectives known for wearing an under
jacket of steel plates to ward off
bullets
both men had been deputized by los
angeles county sheriff james grisham
giving them nearly unlimited power in
the former frontier town
standing there on commercial street the
men were an act of provocation and
intimidation
around 8 15 pm lipiott walked past
belcher belk and at least one other
baldwin felt detective tf douglas where
they loitered outside the toltec hotel
angry words were exchanged
douglas far from an impartial witness
later testified that lipiat threatened
belt that he would see him again when
the detective didn't have his crowd with
him
belk for his part warned lipiat not to
follow him around he said he had no
intention of letting lipiate shoot him
in the back as had occurred in the
northern fields
it was an intriguing comment and when
wade with an earlier comment from lipyat
to strike leader john lawson about the
gunman pressing me pretty hard down in
trinidad it implies that belk and lipiat
had met before or at least knew each
other by sight and character and the
lipiate had reputation with the baldwin
felts men
regardless livia decided the line had
been crossed he strode five doors north
to the packer block of buildings and
climbed the stairs between a hardware
store and a small movie theater to the
union offices on the second floor he
emerged moments later armed with a
handgun and headed for belkin belcher
who had moved down the street away from
the toltec and we're now standing by two
wooden power poles in front of the
poliak brothers pawn shop right near the
corner of elm street 100 feet or so from
where salvation army minister j.w
fleming was conducting a street service
five fellow organizers trailed lippy out
as he cut through the saturday night
crowd urging him to stop
as lipyat neared belkin belcher douglas
had moved on he began yelling accounts
of the exchange vary but generally agree
that lipiat dared belt to repeat his
earlier comments now that olympiad was
armed and no longer alone
luffy out walked up to the two gunmen
pointed his gun at belk's stomach
belcher slapped at lipiat's gun as the
union man fired and the bullet struck
belcher in the left thigh
belk pulled his own handgun and fired
two quick shots that sent lipyat reeling
backward and stumbling to the ground
belk fired twice more and the wounded
belcher added four shots of his own six
of the gunman's bullets hit their marks
one tore through lipiat's throat another
burrowed through his back and lodged in
a lung as the gunshot echoes died away
in the shrieks of the crowd lipios
companions quickly picked him up from
the street and hustled him to a nearby
saloon where he died minutes later
belcher survived
that was before things began to get ugly
and that's when peace still reigned in
the southern district
uh the strike began in
uh mid-september around september 22nd
23rd
uh some of the mines went out before the
official dates was kind of a rolling
walkout
the tent call the strike the union had
already leased land and moved in tents
to set up tent colonies at strategic
locations near the canyon mouse ludlow
turned out to be the main one that's
where the strikers set up their
headquarters
now from that vantage point they could
watch people going into the hastings
mine into the canyon delagua canyon and
also into the burn and tabasco mine so
they could monitor an awful lot of
traffic from one place and harass an
awful lot of strike breakers and that
clearly was the intent of what they were
doing
violence began picking up in kind of a
tit-for-tat manner
there were a few sporadic individual
killings and then there was a
shootout on the streets of walzenberg
the wife of a scab the scab had moved
into the walson mine camp the wife
stayed in the family house in walesburg
the neighbors were all striking minors
they kept harassing her she called for
help from the mine camp to get a wagon
to move her belongings into the mine
camp
a crowd formed the my guards opened fire
three people were killed
in the midst of all these individual
acts of violence
the coal operators began putting a lot
of pressure on
the governor at the time governor elias
ammons to bring in the national guard
the reason for that is you bring in the
national guard and the coal companies no
longer have to pay for their own
security it becomes a state's issue
and the coal operators believe that with
a colorado national guard in the field
that the strike would end
they were under the illusion that a lot
of the strikers stayed up because they
feared violence from the united mine
workers of america
so there's a lot of miscalculations
going on
but in any case the the militia was
called out in late october
and this is a scene
about
general chase
who's he was from denver lived in denver
and his occupation was as an eye doctor
but he was also a soldier of the
national guard
and a little bit of his bio in here
that's kind of an intriguing figure and
a lot of his miscalculations led to the
violence in the field
general chase had been planning for the
call-up since mid-september when
governor ammons warned him to be ready
to move in case a strike got out of hand
a large man with a generous belly and a
wide curling mustache chase 56 cut a
comical figure in his military uniform
like a grandfather playing dress-up
soldier with the grandkids
but chase saw himself as the real thing
a michigan native who like so many
others moved west to make his fortune
chase joined the guard for a few months
in 1887 then resigned but he reenlisted
in 1895. his first confrontation with
labor came in leadville in 1897 and he
played a crucial role in calling the
bloody 1903 strike
although governor amos issued his order
in the middle of the night by the middle
of the next day october 28th chase had
about eleven hundred national guardsmen
and equipment loaded onto trains for los
animas and juarferno counties most of
them leaving from denver
general chase kept specific plans of
what he was going to do close to his
vest even governor ammons the general's
commander-in-chief didn't know how chase
planned to stop the violence
chase ordered his troops to establish
two main camps one at trinidad under
colonel w a davis and the other at
wallsenberg under colonel edward
verdeckberg another veteran of the
1903-1904 crippled creek strike
eventually chase would further divide
troops into 12 camps than 34
ultimately 1600 militiamen would be
deployed to keep peace in a region
nearly the size of connecticut
chase himself rode south of the first
troops and a handful of denver
journalists the general was edgy as the
train traveled with its lights dimmed
led by a single engine sent on a head as
a scout car
early in the trip the engineer of
chase's train break to a stop suddenly
when he spotted a red warning flare
dropped ahead by the scout engine
quote the general ordered everyone to
stay calm but he himself began issuing
loud and conflicting commands
chase told his men that if a battle were
to break out they were to fire from a
prone position
yet he also ordered them to stay in the
train
which meant they'd be shooting into the
side walls of their own cars
after a few minutes report came through
that the lead engine i'm sorry that the
lead engine had hit a cow on the tracks
that was the reason for the flare
gene fowler a reporter for the rocky
mountain news recall that he laughed out
loud and quote the general dressed me
down
fowler sketched out a story in the first
casualty of the troop deployment the
unlucky cow
and sent it to his office by telegraph
at the next station
quote when the general learned that i
had sent this story without first
seeking his approval he denounced me and
threatened to place me in military
custody
so you get a sense of the high caliber
leadership of the of the militia at that
point
um with the national guard coming into
the district the violence kind of ended
um the
striking mine workers initially gave the
national guard the benefit of the doubt
uh but the state budget wasn't doing too
well as it i guess isn't doing too well
right now
the state was running out of money uh
the people who were deployed didn't want
to be deployed
this may be sounding familiar
so a lot of the national guardsmen at
the end of their tour went back to their
homes in denver
they were very quickly replaced by mine
guards uh in the employee of the
colorado field and iron company and
other companies
and in very short order the striking
miners were recognizing the faces of the
hated mine guards in the uniforms of the
national guard and conditions that
deteriorated very rapidly after that as
you might imagine
um
but there was more at play than just the
violence
uh in instigating people and stoking the
flames and probably the best way to do
this is just read you this part
you may recognize this character no
matter how deplorable conditions might
be it takes a spark to start a fire
and general chase and governor amos
concluded that their lives in the strike
district would be a lot more peaceful
without one particular flashpoint mother
jones
as early as september 25th amongst was
complaining about the rabble rouser
telling charles newell editor editor of
the denver express that he thought the
entire trouble to date in the strike
zone was due to the incendiary teachings
of mother jones
how did ammons know what jones had been
saying company spies had been taking
down her speeches and shorthand and the
operator sent copies to the governor
the general and the governor decided
that jones in the district was likely to
cause nothing but trouble so they worked
hard to keep her out
chase's troops were waiting for jones
when she stepped off the train from el
paso at the trinidad station in the
morning of january 4th 1914.
they detained her for a few hours and
put her on another train sending her on
to denver drawing a flurry of telegram
complaints from union officials to labor
secretary wilson
quote mother jones deported from
trinidad colorado by state militia in
violation of all law of the land we ask
you to intervene and protect
constitutional rights of american
citizens and there were scores of
telegrams of that nature
jones to herself took the deportation in
stride getting bounced from a strike
zone was not exactly new in dignity for
her
she wired secretary wilson from denver
that she was heading for washington d.c
and she would like to meet with him he
agreed to see her
but by the time wilson responded jones
plans had changed she had read a
newspaper report quoting governor ammons
as saying that she had been kicked out
of the strike zone and wouldn't be
allowed back in
jones apparently took this as a personal
challenge
she immediately bought a ticket for the
j for the january 11th night train from
denver to trinidad
a supporter warned her that detectives
had staked out a denver hotel and the
train station
so jones sneaked out of the hotel more
than an hour early
bypassing the train station she went
directly to the rail yard and persuaded
the porter to let her board the train
before it went to the station for other
passengers
she sent the porter with two dollars to
ask the conductor to stop the train
short of trinidad and let her off
the next morning jones was in her room
in trinidad's toltec hotel some three
hours before general chase's troops
figured out she was there
roasted her and took her to the san
rafael hospital remember the sisters of
charity a mile northeast of trinidad
where she was ordered held indefinitely
under guard as quote dangerous to the
peace of the community
the arrest naturally prompted another
telegram of howling protests from umwa
president white in indianapolis to
secretary wilson
how long will the federal government
tolerate such outrages prompt action as
necessary to safeguard constitutional
liberty
neither amos nor chase for saw the
inevitable mother jones in a de facto
prison cell was a fragger on which the
miners the entire national labor
movement could and would rally
it's a hilarious part of the history
just to watch that that unfold
those cat and mouse games left and right
she was i think 82 or 83 at the time too
so it was an amazing energy
um
obviously i'm skipping through this
history a lot uh there are 75 people
killed in this thing over seven months
and
pretty much every death is recounted in
this
in doing the book i wanted to
stay away from doing a traditional
strike story
negotiations here negotiations there
what they proposed what they failed
because in reality this was a strike not
about working conditions but about union
representation
they had demand i think was a list of
eight demands
and the first one was union recognition
and there were several times during the
strike where they could have ended the
strike if either side would have budged
on the recognition issue so
there are elements about
increased pay
better hours
accurate checkwomen the coal operators
counted a ton of twenty four hundred
pounds not two thousand pounds
but the one that really mattered was the
union recognition
um
when
let's keep ahead here
the event if you know anything about
what happened in the cold war you
probably know what the ludlum massacre
itself
and it's a continuing mystery as to what
i actually started the violence that day
the the budget wasn't going well again
there'd been a huge snowstorm one of the
biggest ones in colorado's history
there were congressional investigations
there's all sorts of outside
distractions and with those the violence
in the district ended
or at least went down to a low simmer
governor amos decided that the strike
was pretty much over the violence was
over and he ordered the national guard
out
on the morning of april 20th uh there
was only
one full deployment of national guard
troops at the ludlow area and there's
another smaller troop that had recently
been formed in trinidad
uh that morning
carl linder felt will he's probably the
biggest bogeyman there is in this thing
he's lieutenant in the national guard a
soldier of fortune
had very bloody experience in the
spanish-american war in the philippines
he awoke in his tent and somebody wrote
him a letter from a woman who is
complaining that her husband is being
held hostage in the lotto tent colony
a woman named a guy named tuta lamando
they sent a deployment of soldiers to
the tent colony to try to find the sky
they were turned away saying he's not
here uh lieutenant hamrock who was in
charge of the troops in that area called
louis tikas who was a greek leader of
the tent colony
and wanted to meet with him
antiques had been a very not
ingratiating but at least he was he was
willing to talk with
uh hamrock and some of the other leaders
not lindefelt had a history of bad blood
he's willing to talk with the others
but he refused to talk to hamrock this
morning he wouldn't come up and talk to
him
and that made hamrock very suspicious
there are all sorts of rumors floating
around about the
people in the tent colony getting fresh
loads of guns in from aguilar
uh rumors swirling on the tent colony
that before the troops were pulled out
they wanted one last whack at the tenth
colony so tensions were high everybody
was nervous hamrock ordered lindefelt to
take water take hill
i'm sorry water tank hill overlooking
ludlow
and told him to bring the machine gun
and lindenfeld arrived with some fellow
troops and some of them rushed ahead on
horseback at a full trot down to the
depot area
to report to hamrock who at that point
was actually talking to tikas he just
decided well i'll go up and talk to the
guy
so
the strikers didn't have a leader in the
tent colony tikka was with hamrock
the striker saw the machine gun getting
put up
saw the horse traffic back and forth
began grabbing their rifles and leaving
the tent colony going to the arroyo
going to the rifle pits that were going
to a railroad cut east of the tent
colony
the soldiers saw that flurry of activity
and thought oh my god yeah they're going
to do something so they then began
rallying themselves so both sides were
misreading cues misreading signals
early on in the strike the soldiers had
set up a system of signals where if they
set up three dynamite blasts that meant
trouble and the blast would echo through
the canyons and everybody
on their side would come running in to
help
as tensions were escalating
one of the
sub lieutenants in the national guard
ordered the
dynamite blast to be fired as a signal
the guy who actually lit the fuses
testified later that bullets were
pinging around his feet as he lit the
first fuse and the national guard
insisted the strikers began shooting
first the strikers insisted that the
national guard began shooting first as
you can imagine
unaligned people in ludlow said they
heard two dynamite blasts and then heard
bullets they couldn't tell where the
bullets came from so it seems like in
the confusion in the explosion of the
bomb blast
the gunfire began possibly from the
strikers uh thinking that the the
dynamite blast was the beginning of an
attack from the militia but
the end result is overnight for sure
what happened but it began a confusion
and people were misreading signals the
battle ran all day
at nightfall by nightfall
the
armed strikers had pretty much fled the
tent colony
flunk fled the arroyo
seeded the terrain to the militia pretty
much
and that's when the militia moved in
louis tikas
stayed in the tent colony to try to help
people escape
he was moving back and forth between the
tent colony and where the
striking miners had been using the
weapons
but let me make sure i'm in the right
place here
after the the i'm not going to read you
the part about the deaths of the women
and children i'm going to read you about
the death of louis tikas
after
the women and children as i read earlier
suffocated under the under the tent as
it burned above them but nobody knew
they died until the next morning so that
news didn't happen didn't spread until
the day after these events
with the soldiers over running the
colony louis tika sled north and slipped
into the bullets guard pump house
joining the filer another striker who
had hidden there earlier
as the colony burned the militiamen
continued moving northward on the west
side of the railroad cut until they
reached a steel bridge over the delagua
arroyo which had earlier given
protection to
thomas and other women and their
children and which had been used by
armed strikers during the battle
from the bridge the soldiers had a
commanding view of the railroad cut and
routed the last of the strikers ending
the battle
but some of the militiamen found tikkus
and filer and rushtikus a trophy down to
the railroad track down the railroad
track to the crossroads at the southwest
corner of the burning tent colony they
were shutting we got louis the greek we
got louis the greek
they drew a crowd that quickly swelled
to more than 50 men jeers and curses
rang in the night and some began yelling
for a rope to hang ticus as the other
militiamen arrived with filer and yet
another small group walked up with a
third unidentified prisoner
carl linderfeld joined the throng and
took over i thought you were going to
stop this lindefelt's near to tikkus the
two men argued over who was responsible
for the day's violence
tikkus at five foot seven and 150 pounds
was much smaller than lindefelt a
bulldog of a man two inches taller and
some sixty pounds heavier
as the argument escalated lindefell
grabbed his rifle by the barrel and
swung it hard at ticus striking him in
the head and breaking the gun stock
ticus fell face first in the street
blood gushing from a one and a half inch
bone exposing gash on the right side of
his head
lunderfeld ordered an underling sergeant
cullen to watch overtikas and the other
prisoners and then he left his broken
rifle slung over his shoulder
near the depot he met up with hamrock
r.j mcdonald who was a military
stenographer and a third man
the three men had heard the shouts from
tikka's captors and the cries to hang
him
lunafeld assured him the men wouldn't
lynch
lindenfeld assured him the men wouldn't
lynch tikkus
but i broke or spoiled an awfully good
rifle
moments later a few members of the mob
leveled their guns at the defenseless
captives and opened fire
tikis still on the ground was shot three
times in the back
fire was hit on the wrist but another
bullet hit to the right of his nose
slicing through the brain then blowing
out the back of his skull
all three lay crumpled within a few
yards of each other the life draining
out of them into the dirt and the
flickering glow of the burning tents
the militia held on to that zone for
several days and left the bodies there i
left the bodies there so long that
passenger trains from the cns railroad
were coming through and people were
seeing the bodies and that led to
complaints from upper management to
upper cfi's upper management they
finally moved the bodies
um
the reaction by the strikers was very
very quick and very violent
um
those who were deployed around the
district uh working in jobs without the
ten colonies grabbed the rifles headed
for the black hills east of little tent
colony
there was a few outbreaks some killings
that happened in the immediate aftermath
the first day or so but then things
settled out while the strikers were
bearing the debt and there was a lot of
dead to bury
21 or 22 i think from that day alone
but then things stepped up
there was a call to arms
issued by john lawson and the other
strike leaders and union leaders it was
a national call to arms
strikers began pouring in from all over
colorado and wyoming i'm sorry union
people began pouring in from all over
colorado wyoming and other places nobody
knows how many
union supporters wound up showing up
here
but they they sort of organize
themselves into loose battalions
uh nowhere are there any records that
indicate there was any sort of
centralized authority that doesn't mean
there wasn't one it just means you know
the records don't exist in any findable
place
but it looks like the soldiers the the
strikers
fully armed
uh would just
come together as sort of you know
organic fighting forces
remember a lot of these striking miners
were italian immigrants and greek
immigrants and a lot of them had
histories and balkan wars these guys
know how to fight i mean they were tough
figures and they took to the hills and
engaged in essentially a 10-day
guerrilla war against the colorado
national guard
uh it didn't end i'm skipping ahead here
a bit of this next reading but it didn't
end until
this is sort of a telling point when the
national guard was killing people
president wilson didn't think it was
necessary to send in the troops the u.s
troops to settle it out but when it
became clear that the striking miners as
the military force was beating the
national guard they controlled 200 miles
of the eastern slope of the rockies
that's when he decided to send in the us
army you know to essentially defuse the
violence because the striking miners
were winning the insurrection was
winning
one of the the key camps that the
strikers set up there was initially
there had been a military camp outside
of trinidad
and when the national guard pulled out
uh they just sort of left that space
when the striking miners were forming
their own sort of quick detachments of
militias uh they took over that military
camp there's a great picture of their
tents replacing the national guard tents
that have been there and you know these
guys in their rag muffin clothes and
bandoliers and rifles and their their
hats replacing the national guardsmen
who had been there before so it was a
complete flip of circumstances
and they looked uh somewhat comic i was
joking with my son earlier that one of
these pictures looks like almost like an
outtake from a marx brothers movie the
way these guys were dressed
but they were incredibly
adept incredibly well organized
there was one guy named brown john brown
who was a umw
a organizer came into trinidad and
organized the deployment at camp ashore
they called it then
and i'm going to read you a bit from one
the one foray they made that was
incredibly successful where they went
out and attacked the forbes mine camp
they left trinidad left their camp
in the early morning hours and they were
outside
forbes itself at dawn
as dawn light in the sky harris one of
the mine guards spotted a bunch of men
coming over the hill brown and his
miners and they formed a skirmish line
the guards rushed to ready the machine
gun that had been set up in the mouth of
the mine
watson fired off two shots with his
rifle a pre-arranged signal that trouble
was brewing
colorado supply company store manager
k.e cowdery was in
the superintendent's house nicholas
nichols
where he was still on the telephone
trying to arrange for help
none of those men heard the rifle shots
but several men ran in to tell them the
signal had been fired
cowdery hurried out and was in within 50
yards of his house quote when the fire
started like hail and the hail got
uncomfortably uncomfortably close
he ran inside and moved his wife and
children to the kitchen and barricaded
them the best they could with mattresses
the miners laid down a continuous half
hour torrent of bullets answered by the
mine guard's rifles in the sporadic
fuselage of the machine gun
three bullets zipped through cowdery's
house that no one was injured
cuttery took to his back porch partially
shielded by the wooden supports and
fired off shots toward where he heard
the miner's guns up the canyon wall to
the east
the attackers are close enough for
country to hear one of them shouting i
took him to be greek giving orders
strike breaker gus whitney was in the
mule barn when the warning shots drew
him out into the dirt street where he
joined jack smith and a few other men
from the camp
smith asked where they could find cover
i says the best place i know of to get
to is is under that old rock house
across the arroyo
the men ran bullets whizzing past some
finding their mark smith and edward abe
kessler carpenter fell to the dirt
mortally wounded as the others dove into
the stone house
the pace of the gunfire increased and
the men fled again whitney headed for
the arroyo but a striker spotted him and
fired clipping him in the arm whitney
spun to fire back but a second shot
ripped into his abdomen and on out his
back he eventually crawled to safety
near the entrance to mind number seven
he survived his wounds
the mine guards and strike breakers
including a number of japanese kept the
attackers at bay for a time primarily
because of harris and the other men
laying down rifle fire and machine gun
fire from the elevated positions
after 45 minutes they ran out of
ammunition so we beat it over to the
majestic mine and stayed there until the
battle was over
without the machine gun to hold them
back the miners quickly gained the upper
hand
nichols was still on the phone trying to
summon help when the line went dead
about 6 45 am and he and two other men
fled the camp for a hillside another
half dozen strike breakers and guards
also snuck out of the camp hoping to
outflank the attacking miners they were
caught but the miners released them
unharmed up in the hills an action
indicating that while the miners had no
apparent qualities about shooting to
kill their prime goal was destruction
not death
and i
that's probably enough of that um
the last battle
was fought in wallsenberg
and this is one of my favorite
characters of this thing i was telling
people the other day
if anybody ever makes a movie of this
the character that they have to focus on
was a journalist of course
a guy named
mcgregor don mcgregor who's reporter for
the denver express which is a very
left-leaning paper at the time
he went to the strike district when the
strike began and was back and forth
doing stories
after ludlow after the massacre he
dropped his pen and picked up a gun and
he was leading a battalion of the
striking miners in wallsenburg
uh if any of you have ever been to
wallsenberg but there's a big ridge a
hog back that sort of dominates the town
and
the striker seized control of that and
they gave him a vantage point to fire
down on the wallsenberg mine
in the mcnally mine and that battle
raged for two or three days and it was
it was the last element of violence in
the strike and my book ends
with a description of that battle
and it's kind of an intriguing scene at
the end where they've kind of fought
themselves into an exhaustion and there
was a sort of a truce going on at that
point that the u.s army had been called
out everybody knew they were coming they
were tired of shooting at each other
under the truce the strikers were
supposed to turn over their weapons the
strikers refused to the militia didn't
feel like fighting him over that issue
everybody just sort of sat where they
were until it ended
and the most uh army came in uh
the national guard pulled out one of the
requirements that president wilson
issued for sending in the troops was
that the national guard be withdrawn he
didn't want two fighting forces in the
same field for obvious reasons
and a curious thing happened as soon as
the national guard was withdrawn the
strikers disappeared
no more shots were fired they faded back
into the hillsides into the camps into
the ten colonies that were left
their enemies were the national guard
and once a national guard was withdrawn
from the district they figured their war
was over
the strike went on a few more months
officially uh but by then
you know all the blood had been spent
and the union lost the organization
battle on the end
it wasn't it was in september 19
december 1914 when they finally declared
the strike officially over but by then
the coal mines were back working at full
capacity and the unions were essentially
routed
so as i tell people since i started
doing this in essence the
the miners themselves rose up against
this oppressive system and they won the
shooting war but they lost the labor war
they lost the contract battle
that's it
love to
thank you
[Applause]
love to entertain questions if you have
any uh if you do have one raise your
hand and i will very slowly point at you
so they can move the microphone over and
and get your question
and if there's anything about the
coalfield war that you know about are
curious about i didn't read about
because you know i left an awful lot out
i'm more than happy to answer questions
yes in the back i'm pointing slowly
scott um in your book you you do a great
job of setting the stage describing the
life in the mining camps
um
what what were the key demands
for this strike
what were the miners seeking as far as
improvement in their lives
eight hour work day
the right to shop outside the company
stores
uh the right to
have a state i'm sorry an independent
check wayman to weigh the coal they
brought out so they wouldn't be ripped
off by the coal operators but as i think
i mentioned earlier the key issue the
one that mattered the most to them was
the right to organize you know they
wanted the union representation
and you could argue that and as the
companies did that that was actually
something that the union was fighting
for you know not the strikers um but at
that point you know when things got ugly
when the violence happened it was more
than union officials you know who were
firing those guns you know it was the
rank and file and it's clear as you read
through the book and read through you
know all the research and there's a ton
of great research here in denver
available you know first first level
research stuff
um that these guys these guys were
fighting for dignity and they were they
were fighting
uh to
overthrow that that sort of yoke of of
oppressive politics and oppressive
economics
a question over here
yes scott uh
number one uh i've got a couple the
first is did you run across phil van
sice at all in your
in your research on this and then number
two do you really consider this a
massacre
uh van ciser ran across he had some
great stuff and it's in the book so if
you've got a copy you can you can read
about it
he was a very significant figure in sort
of the internal uh national guard
you know obviously you're familiar with
him but but he was a big figure in how
they were addressing what they had done
uh and no i don't think it was a
massacre um
it was tragic obviously
uh anytime 11 kids and two mothers die
of suffocation and conditions like that
it's deplorable but your concept of a
massacre usually involves intentional
directed violence you envision machine
guns shotguns machetes you know it's
kind of an act a forceful act to kill
people
and i'm not a lawyer but you know
my gut feeling is this was at worst
criminally negligent homicide there's no
way to
conclude that the national guard knew
these people were hiding in this hole
under the ground which by the way was
dug initially as a maternity ward they
had no place for pregnant women to give
birth so they dug this big underground
cavern and
you know it's sort of the maternity
chamber
there's no way they could know they were
in there and they torched the tents and
they died as a result of the arson so to
me is criminal homicide a tragedy but
yeah
and what's kind of interesting is a
journalist understand this completely
it's a very dramatic story but to me the
cold-blooding blooded killing by the
national guardsmen of these three guys
that they had captured who are
defenseless is the bigger atrocity yeah
that was an intentional act by these
guys and that was quickly trumped
uh by the attention paid to the women
and children
it was a great story and the unions did
a very solid job of spinning that story
you know they the two women crawled out
of that pit two survived and they put
them on the road and they
did fundraising speeches all across the
country they address congress i think
one of them had a white house visit you
know they did a very good job this is
sort of you know one of the first
examples of sort of modern spin
campaigns
the companies the corporate side is
doing that as well with their own
people uh question in the back corner
yes sir in your research
were the rockefellers and the cfi
really fearful of a cut in production
and therefore productivity profits or
did they look upon the miners
as sub-humans inferior beings
and they could do anything they want
it this is a that's a great question and
the answer is full of all sorts of
nuance um
rockefeller seniors had a kind of an
operating policy of hiring what he
thought were good people
and letting them do their thing so it
was kind of a hands-off
approach to management
and as we know now that can lead to some
pretty disastrous
circumstances
i don't think they were driven by
prophets that much i've read a lot of
the telegrams obviously they're driven
by prophets but in their actions in
colorado i don't think they were they're
driven more by ideology the rockefellers
were stridently anti-union and there are
some quotes in here
from speeches by rockefeller jr who was
kind of running the show at that point
now that he'd willingly risk his entire
fortune to keep unions out i mean it was
a philosophical point with these guys
and lamont montgomery bowers who was
their man here in colorado i was cut
from the same cloth you know
they saw themselves as paternalistic
looking out for their own people
but uh bowers especially was uh you know
as you mentioned you know their approach
to their workers he thought they're a
bunch of just scum just riff-raff and
there's a wonderful telegram
unfortunately i took my bookmark out
there's a wonderful telegram from him
to rockefeller junior uh talking about
how he wouldn't mind
uh
they're talking about a cut in wages
well before the strike and he says he
wouldn't mind doing that to these miners
because they weren't really americans
anyway they're just here to earn money
build up a bank account back in their
home country
drink their i think said
eat their bread and drink their cheap
beer and then go back to their own
countries and he had no qualms about
cutting the wages for people like that
because they weren't real americans you
know so there's a lot of xenophobia
involved in it a lot of classism a lot
of racism
yes
one other thing
you had indicated that the umw
actually lost
as far as their demands but
cf and i started a company union that
gave them everything that the umw had
been had been striking for yeah and that
was an attempt by the company to sort of
fend off any future organizing campaigns
um and that sort of fizzled in the 30s
with the wagner act which outlawed the
community but it took 20 years well
actually in 1927 the wobblies organized
the mines so
even with the company union it sort of
came back
when haywood came back i'm sorry i said
when big bill haywood came back right
right yeah that's that's another
fascinating story
because i know that one is a local
activist named richard myers who
recently authored co-authored a book on
you know that strike
it's a fascinating history in and of
itself but it's interesting there wasn't
united mine workers who won that one was
the wallabies who won that one
uh
wait for the boom right there we go okay
she found you
of the 75 people that died how many were
actually guardsmen or soldiers and how
many were minors or how does that break
down um i wish i had that written down
on the side i have it in the book it was
first of all the 75 figure is a floor
that's all the ones that i could confirm
and i'm pretty convinced that i probably
missed four or five in some of the
outlying counties where i couldn't get
to the to the records a limited amount
of time to do the research so 75 sort of
the minimum
for
this gets very cold sounding but i
subtract the
13 victims at ludlow from that death
list because there were accidental
deaths in essence or
unintentional deaths and of the
remaining i think 38 were mine guards uh
strike breakers yeah they were on the
company side and the rest were the
striking miners
so obviously the strikers lost far fewer
people than they were then they wound up
killing and even when you include the
women and children you know it was
almost a draw at that point
it's kind of a cold way to look at it
but that's what wars are about
any other questions
great thank you very much for the coming
appreciate the time
blood passion scott martell is a staff
writer for the los angeles times for
more on his work visit
dot
scottmartel.com